>>Simon Maxwell: My name's Simon Maxell. I
run a think tank on international development
in London called The Overseas Development
Institute.
I've just heard Bill Clinton say in the ____
Hall how important it is to remember that
this is a global community in which some of
the people most affected by the crisis are
amongst the poorest on the planet. And that's
a really important statement because there's
a tendency to think about the financial crisis
being something that mainly affects developed
countries and that it's a crisis that will
be solved in developed countries. Neither
of those statements is true.
We've seen the recession rolling out and affecting
many poor countries and many poor people on
top of the food crisis and fuel crisis of
last year. We now see countries very badly
affected by lower remittancies for migrant
workers, by falling prices and volumes for
the export of goods and services. Tourism
receipts for example are falling. The reversal
of foreign direct investment, the repatriation
of portfolio flows to developing countries.
These are hitting countries very hard.
Kenya, for example, has lost something like
30% of its tourist revenue, 40% of its remittances.
And if growth falters in those countries,
it will have a very serious long term affect
on the poorest people and those costs will
be irreversible because children who are affected
by malnutrition, for example, in the early
years lose their health, their ability to
learn, their adult productivity.
So what do we have to do? We have to make
sure that we tell the story about the recession
which puts developing countries fully at the
table and their voice must be fully heard
in this exercise. We need to make sure that
the protection measures are available to stop
this crisis affecting poor people. And we
need to think about poor countries as part
of the solution, as well as just part of the
problem. And investment in developing countries
can play a big part in providing the boost
to global growth that is on so many peoples'
minds here at Davos.
We have a number of important opportunities
coming up in the next few months, starting
with the G20 meeting in London in April. The
G20 is not a perfect formulation because it
leaves out many developing countries, but
it's a good start. We need to build on that
and make sure that the measures we take to
deal with the recession don't just affect
us in the North, but really work for all people
around the world and that we have a principled
approach tlicy making.
Let's see that evident from leaders at the
G20 meeting in London _____ leadership in
April.